who here has tried the AI Trend where
you upload a bunch of photos to a shady
website or a shady app and then it gives
you incredible images that kind of look
like you but hyper realistic this is
what I got they all look so bad
like it kind of almost can be somewhat
decent what is that thing sticking out
of my head what do we where do we start
it's just doesn't even the facial
structure I wear tank tops okay I
actually I kind of like this one so
I just think that maybe like the AI
prefers males over females like I would
probably bet all of my money that I have
that whoever made this AI program this
I just thought maybe that that was could
what am I holding up
here angled like it may have run through
a cheese grater or a shredder or
something it's a Vibe what type of shoe
is that yeah well I'll just
just leave this right here